and those of you Tepper students in the back
will be very interested in this.
So we found that the passwords created
by people affiliated with the school of computer science
were actually 1.8 times stronger
than those affiliated with the business school.
We have lots of other really interesting
demographic information as well.
The other interesting thing that we found
is that when we compared the Carnegie Mellon passwords
to the Mechanical Turk-generated passwords,
there was actually a lot of similarities,
and so this helped validate our research method
and show that actually, collecting passwords
using these Mechanical Turk studies
is actually a valid way to study passwords.
So that was good news.
Okay, I want to close by talking about
some insights I gained while on sabbatical
last year in the Carnegie Mellon art school.
One of the things that I did
is I made a number of quilts,
and I made this quilt here.
It's called "Security Blanket."
(Laughter)
And this quilt has the 1,000
most frequent passwords stolen
from the RockYou website.
And the size of the passwords is proportional
to how frequently they appeared
in the stolen dataset.
And what I did is I created this word cloud,
and I went through all 1,000 words,
and I categorized them into
loose thematic categories.
And it was, in some cases,
it was kind of difficult to figure out
what category they should be in,
and then I color-coded them.
So here are some examples of the difficulty.
So "justin."
Is that the name of the user,
their boyfriend, their son?
Maybe they're a Justin Bieber fan.
Or "princess."
Is that a nickname?
Are they Disney princess fans?
Or maybe that's the name of their cat.
"Iloveyou" appears many times
in many different languages.
There's a lot of love in these passwords.
If you look carefully, you'll see there's also
some profanity,
but it was really interesting to me to see
that there's a lot more love than hate
in these passwords.
And there are animals,
a lot of animals,
and "monkey" is the most common animal
and the 14th most popular password overall.
And this was really curious to me,
and I wondered, "Why are monkeys so popular?"
And so in our last password study,
any time we detected somebody
creating a password with the word "monkey" in it,
we asked them why they had a monkey in their password.
And what we found out --
we found 17 people so far, I think,
who have the word "monkey" --
We found out about a third of them said
they have a pet named "monkey"
or a friend whose nickname is "monkey,"
and about a third of them said
that they just like monkeys
and monkeys are really cute.
And that guy is really cute.
So it seems that at the end of the day,
when we make passwords,
we either make something that's really easy
to type, a common pattern,
or things that remind us of the word password
or the account that we've created the password for,
or whatever.
Or we think about things that make us happy,
and we create our password
based on things that make us happy.
And while this makes typing
and remembering your password more fun,
it also makes it a lot easier
to guess your password.
So I know a lot of these TED Talks
are inspirational
and they make you think about nice, happy things,
but when you're creating your password,
try to think about something else.
Thank you.
(Applause)